o surf é um esporte incrível
e quando a gente faz alguma coisa
incrível a gente se sente incrível
simples assim
e foi assim que surge começou a mudar
minha vida começando pela minha
autoestima e eu queria levar isso para
outras mulheres e há três anos atrás
conheci outras três grandes amigas que
eram apaixonadas pelas mesmas coisas ea
gente resolveu criar um site que tivesse
todo tipo de informação para que
incentivasse mais mulheres a iniciarem
nesse esporte tão incrível
o mais engraçado que a gente começou a
receber muitos e-mails de meninas que
pediu a nossa ajuda e que iriam à nossa
companhia
ou seja a gente percebeu que a gente
tinha que sair do maine e prática junto
com as nossas leitoras
o engraçado é que elas tinham um medo e
vocês me perguntam mais lento do que
chris do mar não o medo do que os outros
vão pensar delas então uma porque se
sentia muito velha a outra porque não
gostava do corpo a outra porque se
sentia desengonçado e aí eu deixo uma
pergunta aqui pra vocês refletirem e
pensarem mesmo do fundo do coração o que
hoje faz com que eu você e muitas
pessoas a gente deixe de realizar coisas
incríveis na nossa vida pois bem
nesse mesmo período chegou um momento
muito importante na minha vida que eu
esperava há anos eu estava para terminar
a minha segunda faculdade e teve coragem
de pedir as contas do emprego dos sonhos
dos meus pais e e naquele momento eu
estava livre estava livre para viajar o
mundo pra fazer tudo que eu sempre quis
fazer
sem ninguém me prender mas não deu tempo
eu engravidei e naquele momento nos
sonhos eles parece que sumiram sabe eu
só fui até o meu sétimo mês de gravidez
e muitas pessoas me diziam que eu era
louca mas na verdade aquilo era
justamente o que mantinha minha sanidade
o meu filho nasceu e eu transformei o
primeiro ano do meu filho
no pior ano da minha vida eu não
conseguia entender por que porque é um
dia gostava de ser mãe ou esposa ou dona
de casa e na verdade fui pega por uma
uma negatividade assim que dominou
realmente a minha vida minhas atividades
com as meninas do site tudo virou um
fardo pra mim eu parei de fazer aquilo
com amor e comecei a buscar dinheiro com
aquilo e ao contrário só me deu prejuízo
e feedback negativo das pessoas o que
antes não existia
então decidi que eu tinha que mudar
aquilo de uma vez por todas que não
podia continuar com aquilo
então eu vou buscar algo que eu tinha no
surf e que mexe muito comigo que eu
gosto muito que é justamente o silenciar
porque quando a gente for uma onda
quando a gente surfa uma onda quando a
gente passa uma rebentação os vezes até
tomou um caldo mesmo às vezes talvez até
por questões de sobrevivência
a gente não pensa em absolutamente mais
nada
todos os nossos problemas eles somem
isso porque a gente está vivendo aquele
momento intensamente e eu decidir que eu
ia viver cada um dos minutos do meu dia
e todas as minhas atividades de maneira
totalmente intensa e presente
nisso eu consegui silence alma minha
mente que me atordoava com questões do
passado me acordava com questões do
futuro engraçado que essas duas coisas
não existem eu consegui silenciar e
comecei a me escutar escutar o que tinha
aqui dentro de mim e eu percebi que o
meu filho realmente era a melhor coisa
que aconteceu na minha vida
sem sombra de dúvida a coisa mais
importante e e outra coisa que eu
conseguia escutar aqui dentro que a
minha actividade com as meninas não era
só um negócio on uma atividade social
nada disso era assim uma missão que eu
tenho hoje que é pegar o surf como
ferramenta de empoderamento feminino
porque ele realmente transforma e e nós
mulheres
nós podemos e nós merecemos fazer e ser
o que quis o que queremos qualquer coisa
que nós podemos ser mãe uma ótima mãe e
ao mesmo tempo ser uma ótima
profissional uma ótima esposa é só a
gente escutar o que está aqui dentro e
fazer com amor
obrigado